le voyage d'Emmanuel Macron aux
États-Unis d'Amérique illustrent
l'influence d'un président de la
République française en 2022 cette
visite d'État ne sert à rien Joe Biden
ne fera aucun cadeau et soyez certain
que les voitures européennes électriques
ne bénéficieront pas des primes à
l'achat auront les automobiles
américaines quand je dis que ce voyage
ne sert à rien je devrais nuancer il
permet à Emmanuel Macron de soigner son
image
[Applaudissements]
vive les États-Unis d'Amérique vivent la
France et vive l'amitié entre nos deux
pays reste la com et la décision à court
terme Emmanuel Macron Excel dans cet
exercice il est le prince du vent
l'homme qui séduit l'homme qui parle
l'homme qui prend la lumière mais que
restera-t-il de tout ça dans un an dans
10 ans et même dans une semaine rien le
prince du vent règne sur le royaume du
vide 36 37 et ton point fr
[Applaudissements]
non mais là j'espère que je vais
retrouver mon petit JB en entier sinon
ça va pas aller un black-out partiel
menace la France des coupures
d'électricité sont envisagées en cas de
fortes tensions sur le réseau électrique
cet hiver des plages horaires sont déjà
définies de 8h à 10h de 10h à 13h et de
18h à 20h un cas extrême selon les mots
du président qui tentent de rassurer
sans grand succès franchement on voit
tout allumer tout le temps tout le temps
et moi particuliers on va me dire tes
têtes à Télé talent pour ton poste non
mais on marche sur la tête là la France
en panne en panne d'électricité pendant
quatre bonnes heures et parfois plus
8h27 ce 19 décembre 1978 l'électricité
saute partout en France les ascenseurs
les métros les trains s'arrêtent
certains usagers agarent ont dû être
évacués par les tunnels panique à bord
la méthode électricité a fait son
apparition en octobre dernier à la
télévision pour sensibiliser le public
aux les amis d'électricité pour ça ne
soyez pas surpris si pendant l'émission
à un moment
voilà c'est pour faire des économies
c'est qu'on me dit dans l'oreillette
attention à Mulhouse il y a plus de
courant donc on fait l'émission dans le
noir ce jour-là il a gelé les Français
ont mis le chauffage à fond beaucoup
trop pour le réseau électrique qui
implosent si près de Nancy au même
moment la ligne de 400000 volts de
bézomont déclenchait ou si vous préférez
disjoncter toutes les lignes du pays
sont à leur tour à l'exception de celle
du Nord et de l'Est et déjà on se pose
des questions sur l'avenir toujours
d'actualité il faut mettre l'accent
maintenant sur les énergies solaires les
énergies nucléaires il faut apprendre
aux gens à économiser l'énergie voilà
par exemple encore des piles usagers que
l'on a récoltés que ce soit celle
utilisée parce qu'à la télévision tu
sais on utilise beaucoup beaucoup de
piles et une fois qu'elles sont usagers
beaucoup de villes beaucoup de drogues
c'est la télévision
vous allez complètement vous laisser
porter par le son du
vous allez partir dans un univers
totalement nouveau vous laissez emporter
dans cet univers et dans ce paysage
effectivement je n'aime pas les
religions et je n'aime pas l'islam j'ai
le droit et vous aviez ajouter et vous
aviez ajouté je parle évidemment des
intégrés pour ceux qui veulent faire la
différence existe
pas le mariage d'homosexuel moi j'ai
jamais été anti Mario donc j'ai deux
frères homos selon l'expression que
donne-t-on aux cochon quand on donne
quelque chose à une personne qui ne le
mérite pas
la queue
laquelle
et c'est ce qui est formidable c'est que
on a tous en nous encore un petit un
petit bout d'enfant qu'il faut protéger
on a toujours on a dans notre cœur ça
c'est clair Nagui toi tu as un petit
bout d'enfance ça c'est sûr mais en tout
cas Jean-Luc Lahaye aussi
non on est resté des enfants voilà c'est
ça que je voulais dire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est le fils de Depardieu
avec qui alors effectivement on sait
qu'il a eu il a eu donc Julie Depardieu
qui est la fille de de lui de Philippe
Katerine pardon non la fille de non non
non non non non
c'est un hommage peut-être à tous les
papas qui nous regardent donc merci dans
le fils est malade et qui attend
peut-être qu'on trouve une solution et
une guérison bravo et merci Claudio
là alors oui
c'est un scoop
je choisis parmi les gens qui font 36 37
ce soir ah d'accord un simple joyeux
Noël devenu collector il y a 30 ans
c'est depuis un ordinateur qu'un
ingénieur envoie le premier SMS de
l'histoire reçu par un dirigeant de
Vodafone ce texto s'est vendu il y a un
an à plus de 100000 euros sous forme de
NFC l'agence du SMS et les années 2000
de 2000 à 2012 avec un pic atteint en
2012 exactement avec chaque jour un
milliard de SMS envoyé dans le monde le
score final mon cher Calvez là
[Applaudissements]
78 millions 51
91 euros plus fort que l'année dernière
moins que l'année prochaine mais un très
bon j'espère être battu par le prochain
parent on le souhaite de tout quand même
et je me fais le kiff de dire soprano
Dieu sait que je t'aime mais voilà mon
pote que ça donne quand on fait des
blagues des bisous mon soprano